こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーと
そ）アバンティーズの、そらちぃです
そ）ぐぇ
エ）こいつの家族が大嫌いな
エ）アバンティーズ、エイジです。
そ）おぃ
皆さん！
...というのは知ってるでしょうか。
知らない！
ありがとうございます
モッツァレラチーズゲームというのは
...だけの簡単なゲームでございます
ルールが一つあって
そ）すーーぅ、へへww
ルールは単純なんですけども、
そのテンションの高さをどう表現するかが、
複雑な戦いとなるっていう感じだと思います。
エ）え、ただ声がデカいだけじゃ駄目ってこと
駄目駄目そうそう、この表現力がね。
エ）テンションがね
そう、表現力に問われるっていう。
これ俺ちょっとやろうと思ってたんだけどもぉ
間違いなくくだらないと思いますので
ちょっと下げてたんだけども
今回このバカ二人が来てくれたんで
順番にやってって
前の人よりテンションが高...いなと思ったら
言ってない二人のうち誰かが
（ピポーン）
ははｗ
ピンポンｗて鳴ります
これでクリアって事で良いでしょうか
エ）そうすね
そ）うん
よしじゃあそんな感じで
ぃ行きましょう！
３人）最初はグー
３人）ジャンケンフォイ
３人）最初はグーゥジャンケンフォイ
とりあえずじゃあ俺から行くわ
そ）ずるぃわぁぁぁ
最初はそんな上げないから上げないから。
いきなりトップスピードで行くと皆死んじゃうから
じゃあ、行きます
まずは低めの方が良いよね
モッツァレラチーズ
エ）おー
（ピポーン）
まぁまぁまぁ
最初はね
エ）さっきよりも
そうさっきよりテンション上げなきゃいけない
エ）さっきのよりも
いや
そ）押さないようって言ったｗｗ
言ってない
エ）言ってない言ってないｗ
そ）いくよ
そ）モーッツァレラ、
そ）チーズ
そ）ン、モーッツァレラ
そ）モーッツァレラ
そ）ヂ―ズッｗｗ
そ）何でｗ
そ）何でｗｗ
（ピポーン）
そ）ぅぁははｗ
そ）何でぇｗ
ギリ、ギリだね
エ・は）ギリギリだ
そ）何でそんなやらせた？
エ）良いすか？
良いよ
エ）ンモォッツァレラチィズゥ―↑
（ピポーン）
そ）ゥフフフフ
これは何とも言えないわ
そ）どんどん上げて行くから
エ）徐々に刻んでるから
モッツァレェ～ラチィズ～。
（ピポーン）
決まったな
エ）スピーディーに行ったね
スピーディー、そうスピーディーに行こう。
そ）フゥゥｗ
そ）押さないでしょｗ
そ）モォッツァレラチーズッ
そ）モッツァレラヂーズ
そ）モモモ
そ）モォッツァレラチーズゥ
（溜め息）
（ピポーン）
エ）モォツァ↑
モ"ッツァ"レラチ―ズ！
エ）あ...
エ）結構...
（ピポーン）
ちょっと上げちゃった
エ）上げましたよ
そ）ムゥォッヅァレラ↑
そ）チィズゥゥゥ↑！
は・エ）ｗｗｗ
そ）良いでしょ今のはぁｗｗｗ
エ）えでも結構上がったよｗ
結構上がったよ！
エ）ムァァ！
エ）モッッヅァレラチィー！
エ）あれ？
エ）ははぁ
エ）モ、モ、モ！
エ）モッツァレラヂィーズ！
（ピポーン）
エ）モへへへｗｗ
モ"ォォッズォ
エ"ェェゥ"ッへァア"ッフェェ"！
エ・そ）えへえへえへｗｗ
モォォッズァレラ
ッチィィズゥァェゥァェゥァェーー
エ・そ）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
これはいける
そ）ンモ"ォォッツァルェルァッ
そ）ぅぁチィイィイィイィズゥウゥウゥウゥッ
そ）もう一周行こうよｗ
そ）うふふふｗ
は・エ）もう一周行こ
そ）行く度に押そうよｗ
じゃもう一回やってｗ
も一回見たい
そ）はははｗｗ
もう一回見たいよ
エ）も一回見たい
そ）ンモォオォオォオッツァレラ
そ）あチィイィイィイィイズゥゥゥン
エ）へへへへへｗｗ
（ピポーン）
エ）ハァァーッ！
そ）モーンツァ
そ）モォォォッ
そ）モッツァレラチィイズァァァ！
エ）えへえへえへｗｗ
そ）モッツァレラチヒィｗザァァァ！
（ピポーン）
３人）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
そ）えははははっｗ
はははははははは
ファーーーーッ！
モスロェェァァァッッズァァァァァ！
ォァァァァァァ――――ッ！
（ピポーン）
よし
そ）もうこれ以上無いでしょｗｗ
そ）これ以上無いでしょｗｗ
そ）ブルブルブルブル
そ）モッツァレラチィィ！（カラカラカラカラカラ）
そ）モォッツァレラヂィィィィィィィ！
そ）ム"ォッツァレラ、
そ）チィィィィッ！(/･･)/〇
は・エ）・・・・・・